[Musique]
merci Olivier Pacot de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demiheure vous
êtes élu de loise à par entrer au groupe
les républicains et rapporteur du budget
de l'enseignement scolaire dont on va
parler dans quelques instants mais
d'abord l'actualité on l'a vu ce weekend
c'est cette attaque terroriste qui a eu
lieu samedi soir à Paris un mort deux
blessés l'assaillant avait fait
allégence à l'état islamique c'est ce
qu'a annoncé hier le procureur
antiterroriste il était suivi par les
services de renseignement alors est-ce
qu'il faut revoir le suivi des fichers S
visiblement oui vous savez la dernière
fois que j'étais sur votre plateau
c'était il y a moins de mois c'était
juste
après le meurtre de Dominique Bernard et
nous voilà à nouveau confronté à la même
problématique c'est pas n'importe qui
qui a qui est passé à l'acte c'est
effectivement un individu qui était
connu des services de police et du
renseignement donc un fich S qui avait
fait de la prison pour une tentative
d'attentat hein en 2016 à la défense et
donc visiblement si les services de
renseignement ont bien fait leur travail
puisqu'on sait tout sur lui si les
services de police ont bien fait leur
travail puisqu'il a été neutralisé très
vite avec beaucoup de sang frroid
d'ailleurs on l'a neutralisé avec un
taser il a pas été abattu visiblement il
y a un chaînon manquant dans la chaîne
de protection de la population la
mission première d'un état c'est de
protéger sa population et là c'est c'est
la base du du contrat social mais juste
c'est quoi le chénom c'est une question
de moyens parce que le renseignement n'a
pas les moyens de suivre ces fichè 24h/
24 ou c'est autre chose c'est autre
chose parce que on les connaî on les
connaît donc il faut aller jusqu'au bout
de la volonté de protéger la population
alors aller jusqu'au bout c'est mettre
hors d'état de nuire neutraliser les
individus dont on sait qu'ils sont
dangereux parce qu'ils sont passés à
l'acte ou parce qu'ils disent qu'ils
vont passer à l'acte ou parce qu'ils
sont en contact avec d'autres tueurs et
donc très concrètement il y a la
problématique de la rétention de sûreté
de ces individus faut pas se voiler la
face et quand le ministre de l'Intérieur
insiste avant tout sur le plateau de
télévision sur le problème psychiatrique
de l'individu c'est très gênant parce
que c'est évident que ce type est
dérangé que ce soit un problème
psychiatrique ou une folie politique
c'est une folie aujourd'hui c'est plus
le problème la psychiatrie le problème
c'est comment mettre hors d'état de
nuire ces individus dont on sait
forcément qu'un jour ou l'autre ils
seront des dangers pour la société et
c'est pas du tout un problème on va
revenir sur puisque vous parlez de la
psychiatrie psychire Gérald harmanin a
dit souhaiter que les autorités donc
soit le préfet soit la police puisse
exiger une injonction de soin pour une
personne radicalisée suivie pour trouble
psychiatrique afin de prévenir un
passage à l'acte pour vous c'est pas une
piste à
suivre ça peut mais sincèrement il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin et donc très
concrètement il y a eu en 2000 21 dans
la loi qui a été adoptée des mesures qui
permettent de garder un petit peu plus
longtemps que la peine de prison
prononcé certains individus
effectivement B il faut aller dans ce
sens-là alors est-ce que c'est par une
détention prolongée est-ce que c'est par
un suivi pas psychiatrique mais avec un
suivi judiciaire bien plus
coeritif avec un bracelet et cetera je
sais pas exactement mais il faut aller
dans une mes
beaucoup plus contraignante c'est
évident mais y a des mesures qui avaient
été souhaité dans cette loi qui ét
d'ailleurs porté par brun pivé avec
jainestage brigot qui ont été retoqués
par le Conseil constitutionnel qui a été
saisi par des parlementaires notamment
de gauche est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il
faut reposer une loi ou est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'il faut poser la question
du Conseil constitutionnel alors les
deux mon général effectivement faut
certainement relégiférer et c'est quand
même ennuyeux à chaque fois à chaque
crime de devoir ir relégiférer il faut
certainement relégiférer et puis
peut-être nous allons
visiblement modifier un petit peu notre
Constitution et ben on en tire toutes
les tous les enseignements et on modifie
en conséquence la Constitution en
faisant quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut
renier quelques liberté pour pouvoir
assurer la sécurité je ne sais pas s'il
faut renier des libertés générales mais
euh il y a des individusnel avait dit
juste que ça portait atteinte à la
liberté d'aller et venir que ça portait
atteinte au droit de mener une vie
familiale normale oui alors ça porte
atteinte à la liberté de voyou à la
liberté de tueur et vous savez on est
dans un état de droit mais il faut pas
que ça devienne l'État de droit des
terroristes l'État de droit des voyou
c'est insupportable et effectivement
parfois certaines décisions du Conseil
constitutionnel font tomber les bras des
des gens qui ont du bon sens on se
demande qui veut protéger le Conseil
constitutionnel un texte de loi ou la
population ce qui compte c'est de
protéger la population et de mettre être
hors d'état de nuire des individus qui
ne veulent qu'une seule chose c'est le
mal de notre société de notre
civilisation vous allez demander à votre
président de groupe Bruno retaillot
qu'une nouvelle loi soit déposée du coup
je pense que je n'aurais pas à lui
demander de lui-même les choses sont
prêtes on va parler de l'autre actualité
on l'a vu dans le journal c'est ce qui
se passe du côté de Gaza après avoir
appelé une coalition contre le Hamas au
début du conflit Emmanuel Macron ce
weekend a déclaré que la volonté de
benamine netaniaou de destruction t du
Hamas engendrerait 10 ans de guerre que
pensez-vous de cette nouvelle prise de
position du chef de
l'État c'est le chef de notre diplomatie
mais je trouve que en tant que chef de
diplomatie son cap est parfois fluctuant
et je pense que sa
déclaration n'est pas forcément la bonne
alors elle va peut-être plaire à une
partie du monde arabe elle va déplaire à
Israël et surtout elle va être en
contradiction avec ce qu'il a dit il y a
quelques semaines une diplomatie
efficace c'est pas une
diplomatie opportuniste alors faut être
très clair ce qui s'est passé le 7
octobre oblige oblige Israël à
effectivement tenter de décapiter le
Hamas le 7 octobre il y a eu plus de
1000 morts il y a eu 250
[Musique]
otages si la France était victime de ce
genre de d'attaque de la part d'un
groupe terroriste je pense qu'on en
tirerait tous les enseignements et s'il
fallait prendre 10 ans pour
effectivement décapiter le Hamas et bien
on le ferait les Américains lorsqu'ils
ont été attaqués le 11 septembre 2001 et
bien effectivement ils sont partis dans
une sorte de croisade même si ce mot est
honteux entre guillemets pour certains
et ils ont finalement réussi à se
débarrasser d'Ousama Ben Laden et à
décapiter une grande grand partie de de
la chefferie autour de lui mais là Joe
Biden il dit à Benjamin netan ne faites
pas les mêmes erreurs que nous pour le
le 11 le 11 septembre alors c'est c'est
plus facile à Joe Biden avec deux océans
qui le protègent de pouvoir donner des
leçons à un petit pays qui est entouré
de de gens qui veulent plus ou moins son
bien plus ou moins son mal vous savez le
Hamas le 7 octobre il a voulu une chose
il a voulu
l'embrasement du Proche Orient cet
embrasement n'est pas venu parce que euh
une bonne partie des dirigeants arabes
même s'ils ne portent pas forcément dans
leur cœur Israël ont compris que euh
cette volonté mortifère cette volonté
d'explosion euh n'était bonne pour
personne aujourd'hui il faut soutenir
Israël dans sa volonté de se protéger et
effectivement d'aller jusqu'au bout
contre le Hamas mais effectivement cette
euh ce rouleau compresseur israélien euh
qui fait des victimes VI civile et est
profondément regrettable par le moment
il faut leur dire mais ne pas leur
donner des leçons le le le président de
la République est trop d'honneur de
leçon et tout à l'heure excusez-moi de
revenir sur le drame de de la Tour Effel
moi ce qui m'a profondément choqué dans
la réaction du président on a parlé de
la réaction de Gérald Darmanin il a
tweeté très vite pour dénoncer un
attentat terroriste il n'a pas prononcer
le mot islamiste le président de la
République dans ses analyses soit
volontairement cache des faits ni des
faits soit ne veut pas lui-même les
reconnaître et il y a un énorme problème
pour affronter un ennemi il faut le
regarder en face et il faut le nommer ce
sont des islamistes alors il faut pas
faire l'amalgame et je pense que la
problématique du président de la
République c'est que il a peur que l'on
stigmatise les musulmans évidemment tous
les musulmans ne sont pas des
terroristes mais tous les terroristes
sont des
islamiste on va parler de l'actualité du
Sénat le Sénat qui a poursuivi tout le
weekend l'ex examen du budget avec les
crédits spécifiques dont celui de
l'enseignement scolaire dont vous êtes
le rapporteur on va voir ce qu'il
contient avec Alexandre
[Musique]
Poussard bonjour Alex bonjour Arian
bonjour Olivier Pacco bonjour Alexandre
et Alex l'enseignement c'est donc le
poste de dépense le plus important du
budget de l'État et oui et ce budget de
l'enseignement scolaire pour 2024 va
s'élever à 63 milliards d'euros c'est un
budget qui est en hausse par rapport
l'année dernière plus 6,5 % et cette
hausse elle s'explique car le
gouvernement veut mettre depuis 2 ans
l'accent sur une augmentation de la
rémunération des enseignants le métier
manque d'attractivité les démissions
augmentent Emmanuel Macron avait promis
une hausse de 10 % des enseignants pour
le moment depuis un an et bien la
rémunération de ce métier a augmenté
entre 9 et 12 % pour les débuts de
carrière et entre 4 et 5 % pour les
enseignants en cours de carrière on va
écouter sur sur ce point le ministre de
l'éducation nationale Gabriel Atal dans
l'hémicycle au Sénat je le dis très
clairement nous voulons effacer une
génération de déclassement salarial et
social des professeurs dans notre pays
et nous avons très largement commencé à
le faire en 2020 un professeur
néotitulaire débuté sa carrière à 1700 €
nets par mois c'est désormais 2100 € net
par mois et c'est même 2500 € nets par
mois en r plus c'est 400 € de plus en 3
ans on na jamais vu une telle
revalorisation sur un temps aussi court
au moins depuis les années le début des
années 1990 et puis à cette hausse de
rémunération s'ajoute le pacte
enseignant que le gouvernement propose
c'est-à-dire trois missions
supplémentaires qui sont proposées aux
enseignants sur la base du volontariat
en échange d'une prime par mission une
prime qui s'élève à 1250 € annuel par
mission mais ce pacte enseignant basé
sur le travailler plus pour gagner plus
il n'a pas séduit le personnel de de
l'éducation nationale he puisque
seulement 25 % des enseignants ont
accepté ce pacte alors les sénateurs ont
salué la hausse du budget de
l'enseignement en revanche il regrette
la suppression de certains postes
d'enseignant et oui compte tenu de la
démographie la démographie scolaire de
la baisse du nombre d'élèves et bien le
gouvernement a décidé de supprimer des
classes et de supprimer des postes
d'enseignants 2300 postes d'enseignants
ont été supprémé cela a donc fait
grincer des dents certains sénateurs
durant le débat sur ce
budget
cette chute de la démographie scolaire
aurait pu constituer une auè pour
améliorer notre taux d'encadrement des
élèves qui restent en France un des plus
médiocres parmi les pays de l'OCDE et
effectivement en France le nombre moyen
d'élèves par classe est un des plus
élevés d'Europe à l'école primaire il y
a en moyenne 22 élèves par classe au
collège 26 élèves par classe et au lycée
30 élèves par classe en moyenne donc il
y avait peut-être des mesures à prendre
pour faire baisser ce taux d'encadrement
on va en parler Olivier Pacot mais
d'abord sur l'enveloppe générale de de
ce budget de l'enseignement scolaire
elle est assez ambitieuse pour rendre
attractif le le métier
d'enseignant oui c'était un impératif
d'augmenter les professeurs et ça a
commencé déjà l'an dernier on ne va pas
rattraper le retard tout de suite et les
enseignants français restent mal payé
par rapport à leurs voisins européens
qui soit allemand ou luxembourgeois
mais si on veut raviver la flamme des
vocations parce qu'aujourd'hui un des
gros problèmes c'est d'attirer des
professeurs et dans certains
métiers les mathématiques par exemple on
a effectivement un drame de cette fonte
des des recrutements donc il faut mieux
les payer et les efforts sont réels il
faudra les poursuivre mais si nous avons
voter le budget et si en tant que
rapporteur j'ai demandé à voter le
budget c'est parce que il y a de vrais
efforts faits pour améliorer a le
salaire des enseignants et il le faut
alors le Gouvernement a souhaité même
aller plus loin avec ce pacte enseignant
une sorte de travailler plus pour gagner
plus mais il ne séduit pas les
enseignants seulement 25 % l'ont accepté
ont accepté de faire des missions
supplémentaires en échange de prime
comment vous expliquez cet échec bah
pour une raison très simple c'est parce
que les professeurs contrairement à ce
que certains pensent ils travaillent
déjà beaucoup alors le pacte ce n'est
pas une revalorisation puisque on leur
demande de travailler plus et pour
certains c'est très difficile de
travailler plus parce que ils ont des
déjà euh un une fatigue réelle donc ils
ne peuvent pas il y a des jeunes qui en
ont bénéficié qui sont contents de
pouvoir effectivement accumuler des
heures supplémentaires encore mieux payé
et c'est une très bonne chose le PACT a
permis aussi notamment pour les
remplacements de courte durée de
s'avérer une mesure efficace alors je
dirais comme le Télégramme de Brest le
titit peut mieux faire que ce soit pour
le pacte ou pour d'autres mesures parce
que une une des vraies problématiques du
budget de l'enseignement scolaire vous
l'avez souigné c'est le premier de
l'État dieu merci plus pour longtemps
parce qu'on va être dépassé par la
charge de la dette et bien euh la
problématique c'est que c'est un peu le
tonneau des Danaïdes on en met toujours
plus et l'efficacité en matière euh
d'apprentissage n'est pas forcément au
rendez-vous et dans tout ce que vous
avez dit il y a une chose qui a été
oubliée c'est euh le nivellement par le
bas les classements PISA ou autres qui
sont très mauvais les résultats des
évaluations et le ministre les a reconnu
qui sont catastrophiques qui sont
catastrophiques on a des élèves dont le
niveau est de plus en plus médiocre en
lecture en
mathématique ça pose vraiment question
donc c'est là qu'on veut des réformes
structurelles vous l'avez dit Gabriel at
l'a reconnu il parle de résultats
inquiétants il va présenter mardi son
plan choc des savoirs est-ce qu'il sera
le ministre qui remonte le niveau de
l'école selon vous je l'espère
aujourd'hui c'est le Ministre médiatique
il a un vrai Briot devant les micros il
a su il a eu le courage de dépoussierer
certains tabou il s'est attaqué aux
abayas il prononce des mots que certains
de ses prédécesseurs n'osaient pas
prononcer lors du débat dans l'hémicycle
il a parler de notation et il a
notamment fait comprendre qu'il était
favorable au retour de la notation ben
moi aussi et tous ceux qui pensent que
la pédagogie doit reposer sur une
valorisation des efforts sont favorables
effectivement à la suppression des
petits bonhommes qui souriaent ou qui
faisaient la tête et remettre en place
des notes qui permettent de euh
comprendre quel est le niveau réel de
l'élève et les efforts qu'il a à
effectuer il parle de redoublement aussi
pourquoi pas parce que certains enfants
qui n'ont vraiment pas le niveau c'est
c'est c'est une torture pour eux de
passer les échelons et d'être encore
plus noyé mais c'est trop tabou
aujourd'hui le sujet du redoublement
c'est trop considéré comme un échec ah
bah c'est effectivement c'était même une
non question pour certains pédagogues
entre
guillemets moi je pense que la question
se pose est- ça peut être une chance
pour des élèves en difficulté pour vous
pour certains pas pour tous c'est pour
ça aussi qu'il faut repenser alors on
parle du collège unique il a parlé de de
de groupe de niveau quand j'étais
professeur devant des classes quand on
osait évoquer la problématique des
groupes de niveau c'est-à-dire mettre
ensemble des enfants qui ont à peu près
le même niveau qui soient en difficulté
ou au contraire en avance c'était
quelque chose qu'il ne fallait surtout
pas faire parce que ça allait
stigmatiser les enfants en difficulté et
ben on s'aperçoit que finalement ça a
quelques vertus ça peut avoir des
inconvénients hein mais ça a aussi des
vertus pour faire progresser ses élèves
pour vous ça ne traumatise pas les
élèves de les classer par groupe de
niveau les mauvais les moyens et les
bons dans dans leur dans leurs souvenir
dans dans leur imaginaire de l'école
faut faire confiance aussi aux
professeurs qui savent bien souvent
trouver les mots pour encourager leurs
élèves en difficultés et savoir
valoriser leur progression quand ils
font des efforts donc non moi ça ne me
perturbe pas est-ce qu'il y a eu ces
dernières années un nivellement par le
bas de l'école oui c'est évident c'est
évident regardez euh les copies alors je
ne suis plus enseignant mon épouse est
directrice d'école elle a des CM1 CM2 je
vois régulièrement les copies
effectivement euh je vois
l'appauvrissement du langage je vois
l'appauvrissement de la grammaire c'est
c'est très inquiétant et en tant que
sénateur je reçois régulièrement des
courriers de la part euh notamment de
candidats qui veulent intégrer mon
équipe euh le nombre de fautes
d'orthographe est sidérant
sidérant on veut élever le niveau des
élèves et pourtant le gouvernement pour
des raisons démographiques a décidé de
supprimer 2300 postes d'enseignant vous
dénoncez cette suppression ou elle est
structurelle elle me pose problème même
si euh la baisse forte de la démographie
qui résulte enfin qui abord il y a une
baisse de la démographie scolaire du
fait de la baisse de la natalité il faut
en tenir compte mais le vrai problème
aujourd'hui c'est que via les
dédoublements on a effectivement dans
beaucoup d'endroits des classes de 12 et
c'est une bonne chose et le gouvernement
ne cesse de glorifier l'efficacité
pédagogique des petits effectifs sauf
qu'à côté on va fermer des classes parce
qu'ils ne sont que 18 et ils vont
devenir 22 23 25 et les élus ou les
parents d'élèves concernés ne
comprennent pas qu'à quelques kilomètres
de distance ils ont des petits cousins
qui sont 12 par classe et eux ils vont
être 30 31 32 dans des classes à double
triple quadruple niveau donc il y a un
problème de justice scolaire
d'efficacité scolaire et de justice
sociale donc il faut revoir cette
problématique et une des choses que le
ministre n'a pas du tout évoqué moi je
je l'ai défié là-dessus ces
prédécesseurs avaient parlé de réformer
la carte de l'éducation prioritaire ils
ne l'ont jamais fait
il faut revoir le périmètre il faut
revoir aussi la problématique est-ce
qu'on passe de zone à des écoles
d'éducation prioritaire pour moi c'est
la solution faut faire du point de croix
et mieux répartir les moyens mieux
répartir les moyens en ruralité il y a
de la misère sociale il y a de la misère
scolaire elle est totalement nié ignoré
merci Alex tout àure on parlera des
questions posées par l'attentat de la
tourffel ce sera à suivre dans le club
on va voir l'actualité dans votre région
pour terminer Olivier Pacot on va
retrouver Jean-Marc chobocher bonjour
Jean-Marc merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous rédacteur en chef adjoint au
Courrier Picard Jean-Marc vous vouliez
revenir d'abord sur les déboires des
usagers de la ligne pariscalis
oui c'est ce qui fait la une du Courrier
Picard ce matin Orian et c'est un
problème très simple en réalité la
tempête de cet automne a dégradé
considérablement les voies du côté de
Boulogne surmer ce qui fait que les
trains Paris Cala sont tout bonnement
supprimés ils s'arrêtent euh à à étaple
et ensuite les gens prennent des carts
de substitution sauf que sur
l'application de la SNCF vous pouvez
toujours continuer à réserver ses trains
8 jours 15 jours 3 semaines à l'avance
alors qu'on sait que tous ces trains
vont être supprimé jusqu'au mois de
février mais la SNCF ne sait pas
supprimer les trains en avance ils sont
supprimés à partir de 17h la veille pour
le lendemain vous imaginez la galère des
usagers qui apprennent quand ils
arrivent à la gare que leur train est un
train fantôme qui n'existe pas et vous
avez une question
Jean-Marc alors la question que je peux
poser à Olivier Pacot qui le le les
transports dépendent de la de la région
bien entendu mais si en tant que
sénateur est-ce qu'il a des remontées de
terrain fréquentes sur ces soucis de de
train qui sont vraiment une galère pour
le pour pour les usagers puisque en plus
nous sommes dans une région la Picardie
qui qui qui est hyper connectée avec la
capitale nous avons énormément de de de
salariés qui vont qui vont travailler à
roissie enfin tout ça on le sait est-ce
que en tant que sénateur Olivier pot est
au fait de ses problèmes et que peut-on
faire oui cher Jean-Marc bonjour Alors
Olivier paco est tout à fait au fait
parce qu' Olivier paco est usager de la
sncfivier prend la voix Paris beauovvet
Paris chantil Paris crille Paris
Clermont Paris crépill envallois et
effectivement il est très rare un que
les trains soient à l'heure deux que les
trains soient complets c'est-à-dire
qu'au lieu d'avoir quatre rames on en a
deux et on est comme dans le métro moi
je ça m'arrive régulièrement de prendre
des des paris chantillly alors ça ne
dure que 25 minutes dieu merci mais où
la moitié des usagers sont debout ce qui
est totalement scandaleux parce qu'il n
a que de rames au lieu de quatre euh il
y a un mouvement qui a été créé il y a
quelques années qui s'appelle la SNCF
matué qui est animé entre guillemets par
des usagers de loise et je ne suis pas
le seul parlementaire mais je fais
partie des parlementaires qui montent
régulièrement au créneau auprès des
responsables de la SNCF pour leur
demander effectivement de d'améliorer la
situation alors ça se fait
ponctuellement et puis on a après euh
des mois ou des semaines catastrophiques
il y a quelques jours des trains ont été
dégradés en gare Damien Jean-Marc doit
le savoir ça c'est traduit par
effectivement une pénurie de train avec
des suppressions non informé entre
guillemets et puis des trains raccourcis
qui obligent les usagers à voyager dans
des conditions qui sont en en terme de
sécurité totalement irresponsable et et
insupportable bien sûr donc
effectivement il y a beaucoup de choses
à changer
je pense que la SNCF le fait ou le sait
en tous les cas est-ce qu'elle fait le
nécessaire à chaque fois que j'ai un
responsable il me le dit mais je ne le
constate pas moi-même qui prend le train
au moins quatre fois par semaine oui
Jean-Marc vous avez une dernière
question plus politique cette fois mais
oui Orian nous pourrions évoquer le
récent exemple de de division qui s'est
produit chez LR
avec la loi sur sur l'immigration et euh
je rappelle à nos téléspectateurs mais
il sera plus qualifié que moi pour le
dire qu'Olivier Paco n'appartient pas au
mouvement politique à l'air mais qu'il y
ait
apparenté au sein du du Sénat alors en
tant qu'apparenté Olivier Pacot est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas que avec ce qui
s'est récemment
passé cela pourrait prouver que l'avenir
de la droite ne passe pas forcément par
LR je vous pose la question parce parce
que vous êtes devenu l'homme fort de la
droite dans l'Oise alors que vous
n'appartenez pas au mouvement politique
àair et vous au vu des résultats au
derni sénatorial l'homme fort de la
droite dans l'Ouest c'est vous alors la
situation de du parti LR effectivement
qui semble parfois manquer de cohésion
et de cohérence en tout cas à
l'Assemblée nationale elle me navre au
Sénat au contraire il y a une véritable
cohésion et cohérence peut-être que la
problématique deslr c'est non seulement
une question de ligne mais aussi une
question de gouvernance un chef doit
savoir Cheffer disait jadis Jacques
Chirac aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
nationale ça part dans tous les sens
aujourd'hui et depuis un certain temps
et beaucoup de d'électeurs de cette
famille politique sont désemparés et si
on continue comme ça effectivement
l'avenir des LR je le vois mal
effectivement donc il y a des choses à
changer ériic cioti est venu devant le
groupe LR au Sénat il y a quelques jours
euh les sénateurs lui ont fait part de
leur mécontentement quand à sa façon de
gérer son parti à lui d'en tirer les
enseignements lesquel pour vous
qu'est-ce que vous en attendez alors il
y avait un cas précis c'était le CA
Pradier qui a été évoqué et certains
sénateurs qui sont air et qui cotisent
étaient prêt à rendre leur cte si
Monsieur Pradier effectivement
continuait à faire son petit jeu
personnel et pour vous B pardon il faut
l'exclure pour vous il faut être
cohérent et j'ai dit un chef doit savoir
che fait donc effectivement il a plus sa
place merci Olivier Paco merci Jean-Marc
chevaucher on regarde la une du Courrier
Picard C TER fantôme c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup Jean-Marc
d'avoir été avec nous et merci Olivier
Paco merci à très vite dans 20 minutes
on va revenir sur l'attaque de Paris
dans le club des territoires qui a eu
lieu attaqu Liu samedi soir sur les
questions qu'elle pose en matière de
suivi des fichess et de des radicalisés
sortant de prison on verra tout ça dans
20 minutes on accueille d'abord Antoine
Basbous qui nous rejoint